- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians!
I wanted to talk to you
again about mutant plurals.
So to review a mutant plural is,
there are only seven of them in English,
and they all change sound
when they pluralize.
You don't add an -s, you don't add an -en,
you don't change the ending,
you change the vowel,
and there are only seven to go like this.
There's man,
woman,
tooth,
foot,
mouse,
louse,
and goose.
And these words become in the plural
men,
women,
teeth,
feet,
mice,
lice,
and geese.
Now the reason that we have
these seven weird mutant plurals
in English is kind of
complicated, but I'm lucky enough
to be able to work with
an actual linguist.
Hello, Jake!
- [Voiceover] Hey, grammarians!
- [Voiceover] Jake, is it
true that you're a linguist?
- [Voiceover] Yep, it's true.
- [Voiceover] All right,
so Jake, what is the deal
with feet?
Where do these mutant plurals come from?
If we take the word foot and
we drag it through history,
how do we get to the plural as feet?
What's the deal with that?
- [Voiceover] So if you look
at a lot of Germanic languages
that are around today, you
find similar words to the word,
the English word foot.
In German we have the word Fuss,
in Dutch we have the word voet.
And when you have a lot
of different languages
with slight variations of a word,
it means there is some
old, old word out there
that all these words are coming from.
So we can pretty much be sure
that there's some Proto-Germanic word
that sounds something like foot.
Now back in those days
there was a different
way to form the plural,
and that was to add an i
sound at the end of a word.
So if the word was foot, then
the plural was maybe footi.
That means many foots.
Now there's a tendency in language
that you have to understand here.
It's called vowel harmony.
Basically it means that
vowels within a given word,
they like to sound like each other.
So if you have two syllables
those syllables will start,
the vowels in those syllables
will start to converge.
And in Germanic languages especially,
there's one typical kind of vowel harmony
which is--
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] When you
have two vowels in a word,
the first vowel will try to sound
more like the second vowel,
if that second vowel is the i sound,
just like in the plural
formation of nouns.
- [Voiceover] So you're
saying that the suffix -i
at the end of this proposed word footi,
the u sound tried to sound
more like the i sound.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] This is just
a pattern that we find
in Germanic languages.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
It's very prevalent in Germanic languages,
also exists in some Romance languages,
some tiny Romance languages.
- [Voiceover] So what happens
when you combine the u sound
with the i sound?
What sound do you get?
- [Voiceover] Well, strangely
you get the ü sound.
- [Voiceover] Are you, what is that?
- [Voiceover] The ü sound.
- [Voiceover] Are you okay?
- [Voiceover] I think I am okay.
You know, we linguists have to deal
with this kind of thing all the time.
- [Voiceover] (laughs) Sorry.
- [Voiceover] We have
very strong stomachs.
- [Voiceover] Uh-huh.
- [Voiceover] You still
get this sound in languages
like German and Dutch.
- [Voiceover] So then that's
what this ü is, right?
So this sound, or I guess,
so the plural of German Fuss
is what you said?
Füsse?
Okay, so bring this home for me.
So at some point in the
development of English,
or of all these Germanic languages,
we had this word foot and
then it turned into footi,
and then it turned into what?
It turned into füti?
- [Voiceover] Something like füti, right.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] Now eventually that ü sound
dropped out of English,
which is why it's so
hard for us to pronounce,
and it was replaced in
pretty much all cases
with the ii sound.
So we get the word feeti
and then the i drops off,
and we're left with foot as the singular
and feet as the plural.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
So it goes from foot to feeti.
- [Voiceover] Now the
same exact thing happened
with the word mouse, which
probably used to be moos,
because in Frisian, which is
the closest cousin to English,
the word for mouse still is Muus.
- [Voiceover] Moos?
- [Voiceover] And you find similar things
in a lot of Germanic languages
like muis in Dutch and Maus in German.
The plural became muusi,
and then eventually meesi,
then you get mees.
Then a few hundred year later,
during the Great Vowel Shift
that mees becomes mice.
A lot of ii vowels in
the Great Vowel Shift
about 500 years ago became ai vowels.
- [Voiceover] So this is
sort of a broad pattern
these mutant words all take.
It's this umlaut mutation, right?
Because these little, these
double dots that go over a,
oh it looks like a smiley face,
that go over a vowel
change its color, right?
They change its meaning.
- [Voiceover] And that process is called
either umlaut mutation or i-mutation,
not eye like the sight organ,
i like the letter in English.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
Well, I hope that cleared
some things up for you.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Jake out.
(clap)
- [Voiceover] That was
a high five, not a slap.